hi i'm ryan wright and i'm jerry welcome
to reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to see snitch
so let's hang out
ryan's consensus
there are some strong reasons to see
snitch there are some strong reasons to
see snitch yeah i mean i had very low
expectations for this film so i was
pleasantly surprised by how effective
this film actually was jerry's consensus
there are definitely some strong reasons
to see snitch there are some strong
reasons to see snitch you know i was
kind of in the same boat with you i was
like eh i don't know if this is gonna be
any good and it's you know it's solid
it's solid all around reason to see
number one
dwayne johnson so we don't call him the
rock anymore do we no i think he's i
think he's earned the right to be just
dwayne johnson now yeah that's that's
fair that's fair it's it's been a long
time since scorpion king
yeah because because we're watching him
for more reasons than just look how big
he is you know
so i think he can be duane though well
dwayne johnson is surprisingly effective
in this role i wasn't expecting to be
this impressed with his performance not
because it's like oscar worthy or
something but because he's really grown
as an actor i mean for a film that's not
an action movie he surprisingly carried
it very well yeah i mean he's definitely
solid and there's a lot of times where
you can you know really feel for him and
identify with him yeah the only thing
that takes away from it at times is the
fact that he's
enormous so it can be a little bit
distracting but other than that i mean
he did a great job you're right he he is
like the buffest father in the world but
at the same time i thought it was smart
to have like the the wardrobe not
emphasize his muscle so much so it
wasn't as distracting to see him on
screen
playing this really compassionate father
and plus two you know he's the boss of a
construction company so it sort of makes
sense why he's you know physically fit
extremely physically fit yeah i think
like it would have been more distracting
if like arnold had played this role yeah
i said it would be like you give me back
my son i'm just trying to run the
business but you know the rock isn't he
does like have an and naturalness about
him that does make you believe
what he's what he's up to he's got a lot
of natural charisma anyway so any of his
flat moments aren't ridiculously
distracting because he's got that
natural charm and he's very earnest
there were moments where i was like
well that was a bit off but for the most
part he's pretty solid solid as a rock
and those moments where he's a little
bit off they don't pull you out of the
movie that much look all i gotta say is
watch the scorpion king then watch this
movie and i think you two will be
impressed with how much he's grown as an
actor so basically you recommend people
watch the scorpion king yeah watch the
scorpion king
then watch race to witch mountain and
then watch this it'll be a good rock
triple feature
no yeah i mean uh dwayne johnson he's
definitely improving every movie he gets
closer and closer to being a really good
actor and he has a lot of solid moments
you know it's there you know he's just
gotta keep going i really respect the
fact that he challenged himself with
this role i i just hope that audiences
are willing to give them a chance as
well because this is not an action flick
and it's not a comedy and we're so used
to seeing them in those types of genres
that i really hope that people are
willing to stretch their imaginations
just a little bit reason to see number
two john bernthal i love this actor i
mean by far he was the most believable
and effective part of this film for
crying out loud his performance is
extremely layered and you can feel his
character's dark history you can feel
the good and the bad in him i mean there
are those moments where you could really
feel the bad in him but overall you
could just feel everything about him he
just does a fantastic job bottom line
yeah i mean he i think he's my favorite
part of this movie overall i mean he
just he's really believable and super
authentic you know you really learn to
care for him in a way that's not like
ham-fisted or cliche you know he brings
a lot of dimension to the character yeah
you said the word authentic and you know
how much i love that word you do yeah
and uh he's the most authentic part to
this film one might say your love of the
word authentic is very authentic yes
authenticity is the key to john bernthal
i mean it's a real three-dimensional
performance even though the movie is not
in 3d yeah and i hope more people will
notice how good of a job he does plus
you know he works very well with dwayne
not the rock johnson that's gonna be his
new name on credits now dwayne not the
rock johnson no yeah i mean i mean some
of the some of the scenes with them
together are my favorites in the film
you know they play off each other really
well they have a good tension and a good
chemistry with one another and i i
really do hope that john bernthal
continues to get roles from this because
between the walking dead and now this
like he is a terrific actor reason to
see number three
the supporting cast i love barry pepper
isn't he just so [ __ ] awesome always
he's always awesome no matter what
facial hair they put on him yeah yeah i
mean the man consistently delivers it's
one of the smaller roles in the film but
he really brings the character to life
and i mean even though they don't
provide him with like much dialogue or
scenes to tell us about his history or
about his personal life it's very
apparent that barry pepper you know
prepared all that already for the role
because you could just feel it all in
his lines of dialogue
even though he's not talking about his
past or anything it's all very much felt
that there's probably some type of
trauma definitely and you know barry
pepper is one of those guys who i'm
always happy to see pop-up places and i
get why hope keeps getting more roles
but you know who else i liked um i like
the actor who played dwayne not the rock
johnson's uh son i thought he was really
good you know he didn't have a ton of
scenes but he did have a lot to do in
the short amount of time and i thought
he and and dwayne johnson had a good
chemistry together and i believe them as
father and son even though he's like a
white kid and i don't know what dwayne
johnson is yeah dwayne johnson's like a
black filipino dwayne johnson dwayne
johnson is like cliff curtis's really
buff brother we're like where are you
from
you can be kind of anybody i guess
definitely the father-son relationship
between them is very believable i mean
there's this one moment where
dwayne the
not the rock johnson gives his son uh
you know a kiss on like the cheek or
something and i wasn't distracted by the
fact that
dwayne johnson did that because normally
i'm like that much older actor just
kissed that much younger actor on the
cheek
but i i was like no that father and son
i totally buy it i mean besides the
little kiss on the cheek i'm sure
there's a lot more to come from this
actor because he does a very good job in
the role it's another very layered
performance in this film uh you know you
know who i like too is i like what they
did with susan sarandon even though
she's a good guy so to speak she is
still kind of like difficult to deal
with susan sarandon's good at playing a
[ __ ] yeah a little bit you know and i
bought her as a federal prosecutor who's
like on your side but only because it
benefits her like that sort of thing so
it's like you're only good because
you're on the right side of the fence
yeah she she really brings life to the
performance like there is a kind of a
nasty side to her but at the same time
the audience really grows to like her
like when i was watching the film people
were laughing at a lot of the things she
was saying because it's she has some
funny dialogue and she's she's likable
in the role even though she's not a very
likable person and it's difficult to
make a role uh likeable when the
character herself is not that likable
and i like the way that she and barry
pepper played off each other too
because it it brought some more
dimension to what was going on and and
the sort of clash of their motivations
and how the rock gets caught in the
middle of that i thought was something
that actually helped everything to sort
of feel a little less cut and dry and a
little less like preachy i guess you
would say you know it brought a certain
greatness to things which i appreciated
and you know another person the
supporting cast who's probably featured
more in the commercials than this actual
movie is benjamin brad yeah i know he
did a good job even though he he is only
in it for like a grand total of like two
and a half minutes
even though he's barely in it there was
something that was actually effective
about having him in this role well yeah
because i because he is like you know a
big presence so it makes sense to get a
guy like benjamin wrap to be there and
to be that big presence yeah because
it's supposed to be like the leader of
the drug cartel yeah and he's elusive i
like the actor who played malik too the
the sort of small time drug dealer yeah
um you know i thought he did a really
good job he was really interesting to
watch and and uh
those scenes where he squared off with
the rock and with uh jon bernthal no
he's not the rock anymore with dwayne
johnson
and john bernthal we're really good yeah
i was surprised by how much this entire
cast brought so much depth to this whole
movie reason to see number four
it's entertaining this film is a
surprisingly effective drama yet i still
feel like it's just a cool flick to
check out yeah i mean it's really solid
all around and while it's not a great
film i think if you cut it at like a
matinee or something i think you'd
really enjoy it see i don't even know if
it's just the matinee that you would
enjoy it at i think a lot to do with the
viewing of this movie has a lot to do
with whatever preconceived notions you
might already have like i had very low
expectations so i was like delightfully
surprised but if you're like a huge fan
of dwayne johnson for his action films
or comedy films or little kids films
he's done it all yeah i think there's a
possibility where you might be let down
because the marketing campaign for this
film makes it look like it's this
extreme action flick but it's really not
i mean it's a crime drama with elements
of a thriller
but just because it's not an action
flick does not mean that this film is
not entertaining it really is and it's
thrilling throughout it's a crime drama
with elements of a thriller and just
because it's not an action drama like
how this how the trailer advertises it
to be does not take away the fact that
this film is still entertaining
throughout yeah i mean i think it comes
down to just don't go in expecting a big
loud action movie because there's more
going on than that you know it's not
about
car chases and explosions you know it
gives you a little more than that to
hold on to and i'm happy
like you i was pleasantly surprised
there's barely any action in this movie
like really
close to none yeah in this film
but
what's weird about it is there's a lot
of films that are bombarded with action
but lack substance
a good day to die hard oh imagine if
john mcclane was was in this movie and
he would like have killed all of mexico
john mcclane versus the drug cartel
but anyway because this film actually
has like
a lot of substance to it even though
there's just a little bit of action
those tiny bits of action are
surprisingly more effective than a lot
of films that are just loaded with
action but yeah because it goes to show
you like what works with any movie works
here you know it's like you care about
the characters and you care about what
they're working for so you don't need
tons of action to you know distract you
because there's characters you know a
little bit of characterization and some
story attention goes a long way and i
think if you can warm up to the fact
that there's only like
one and a half action scenes in this
movie uh you'll you'll really enjoy the
ride it's it's strange because you know
even though this film is overall like a
very serious film i still found it to be
an entertaining flick and i don't often
say that about films that have this
serious of a tone yeah i agree it's like
it's not it's serious it's more serious
than a big dumb action movie but at the
same time it's not so serious that you
won't enjoy yourself while you're
watching it and the you know the
thrillery aspects keep it you know as
somewhat of a ride still yeah i agree
because the drug deal world in this
movie it seems authentic and it seems
very believable so when these characters
are put in like high-stakes situations
it can be scary at times it can be very
intense
so there's an escalating tension going
on here and it works surprisingly well
because the world is very believable i
think it's one of the good surprises of
2013 because we've got in like already
we got on the last stand we got parker
bullet to the head a good day to die
hard and
dwayne not the rock johnson
decided to take on a movie you know
challenge himself to a role that was so
opposite from those movies that i hope
people aren't going well it's just going
to be another
shitty tough guy movie because there's a
lot to check this movie out for like not
just for the performances but for like
the thrills as well
you know there's also like subtle
messages about the drug cartel and
america stand against the war on drugs
that i found to be very effective in
this piece yeah definitely because it
gives you a look into all the different
sides of it without being preachy or
without pushing you into you know a
certain message like i didn't really
feel the film had an agenda you know
it's like the rock is caught between all
these people who have their different
agendas and finally he has to deal with
all that [ __ ] and then finally just
all he wants is his son and it's
interesting to see all the other things
that happen around him while people are
trying to work with him even the good
guys are not totally admirable so
there's a lot of interesting gray area
stuff that they play with that i
particularly appreciated so
yeah absolutely and like the last thing
i got to say about this film is this
like bottom line the thrills work the
performances are effective the crime
elements work but there's also a lot of
emotional drama in this film that is
surprisingly effective as well you know
between there's a lot of like uh themes
about father and son going on in this
film or being a family man what would
you do for your what would you do for
your family that i found to be actually
enjoyable to watch and you know a large
part of why it was so effective is you
know obviously due to the combination of
the writing and the acting oh yeah and i
mean
there are some flat moments here and
there with some of the some of the
dialogue and a couple of the acting
moments but everything's everything
works really well and everything's
believable and there's a lot more you
know substance to it than you might
think you know it's it's not the
greatest film out there but it's it's
actually really solid and a very
enjoyable movie
all right guys this has been reasons to
see thank you guys for checking it out
if you like the video like the video
below and uh tell us your reasons to see
or not to see
snitch and last but not least
subscribe
subscribe
subscribe subscribe people also check
out ryan writes straight to the point
review of snitch yeah if you don't like
seven to ten minutes however long this
video is
then check you know how long it is yeah
so you can tell right down there how
long the video is right oh that's how
long yeah that's how long it is
interesting hey maybe we can play it in
hd click it here well yeah i mean if you
don't want to like watch this whole
thing you can check out the one minute
version of just me yeah no chair if you
don't like really long videos and you
also hate me
you can watch ryan wright's review
you